It goes without saying therefore that you have to be supremely fit...
...to compete in the Tour de France.
Many experts rated the toughest of all major sporting events...
...and participants burn up to 7,000 calories per stage.
Bear in mind that an average person in a day would burn 2,000.
Heart rates can also reach dangerous limits...
...when climbing stages reaching upwards of 200 beats per minute.
But aside from being a supreme athlete...
...and having to overcome the physical and mental challenges of the race...
...as well as having a good team behind you,...
...you need to also have a bit of luck...
...and nerves of steel as there are many hazards...
...that can reduce any rider's dream of winning the Tour into a nightmare.
There's a lot to the Tour de France that all of it makes for one of the most amazing...
...and memorable sporting events and spectacles on the face of the planet.